quelle année pour vous on vous a vu dans
une affaire criminelle où vous incarnez
une femme qui va faire une santé son
fils et le réalisateur Stéphane Lapointe
a dit Catherine si Céline c'est vrai ça
en grande partie
en grande partie c'est sûr que je
Catherine n'en donne un petit peu plus
que moi dans vie par exemple
ça demande justement effectivement de la
lumière quelqu'un qui que du Got
beaucoup qui est entêté des fois je le
suis fait des fois je le suis
effectivement je peux être entêté mais
quel drôle de hasard parce que dans une
affaire criminelle Catherine veut faire
innocenter son fils et dans le film au
nord d'Albanie de Marianne porlay qui
prend la fiche vendredi vous incarnez
amis qui fuit parce que sa fille a
commis un crime comment vous voyez ce
hasard là
c'est sûr qu'on me confie ce genre de
personnage là qui se bat qui
qui rencontre beaucoup d'obstacles j'ai
beaucoup fait ça je le sais pas je dois
avoir une une énergie qui correspond à
ça je suis quelqu'un qui aime beaucoup
bougé qui a beaucoup me battre qui est
plutôt sportif physique puis je sais pas
peut-être que ça donne comme ça
ça marche quand on édition te dit que
gosser maintenant tu vois tu viens
espoir mais j'aime ces personnages là
parce qu'ils vont ils vont vraiment dans
toutes sortes de direction pour arriver
à leur fin
ça demande beaucoup d'énergie et de
volonté c'est des obsessions je pense
que je suis obsession aussi ça se
traduit comment soit être obsessé mais
quand je rentre dans le travail ça veut
dire qu'il faut le Light je pense quand
on travaille dans
je dirais au théâtre dans les tournages
aussi c'est tellement un travail de de
fond comme de course de fond parce que
c'est c'est long d'habitude
de cheval de traître vous l'avez lu les
critiques sont unanimes pour une affaire
criminelle là les critiques s'apprêtent
à sortir pour au nord d'Albanie comment
en tant comédienne vous vivez ça
justement l'attendre la sortie des
critiques qu'est-ce que ça vous a fait
tout pas du tout il y a deux écoles de
pensée
moi je les attends pas parce que je les
lis pas parce que j'ai appris un moment
donné que ça peut me blesser mais moi ça
fait 30 ans ça fait mais je fais ce
métier là fait que un moment donné ça
fait 28 ans je pense que
certaines quand on me dit Lila vraiment
celle-ci mais c'est pas bien bon de lire
des critiques pendant qu'on joue non
plus ça nous influencer trop puis pour
les tournages une fois que c'est fait
c'est fait je fais ce que je peux quand
je fais moi
il y avait un anniversaire cette année
pour vous ça faisait 10 ans vous avez
joué sous un guerrier puis dans l'unité
9 2012 à 2018 je savais pas c'est vrai
j'ai pas réalisé
dans ma cellule et quoi
j'ai perdu ma trousse de toilettes
lavez-vous mise dans un tiroir Suzanne
ou elle existe toujours
est toujours pas loin en fait mais
toujours pas loin parce que
elle habitait un espace intérieur qui
qui touche beaucoup à mon enfant puis il
y a quelque chose du de la du sans
filtre que j'aime avoir ou que j'essaie
d'atteindre le plus possible en jouant
elle le permettait beaucoup donc c'est
pratique ben c'est pratique de penser à
ça cette espèce d'espace de liberté en
fait de réaction de jeu je trouve que ce
personnage là portait ça et jamais bien
loin je l'ai beaucoup aimé je l'ai
beaucoup aimé ouais qu'est-ce que tu
deviens
cardiologue
votre prochaine série c'est la semaine
prochaine sur le site du Point TV
fragments
là où on dévoile certains secrets je
veux tout savoir sur
fragments c'est une écriture qui avance
tranquillement mais profondément dans la
simplicité aussi d'une de cette amitié
là puis de l'importance que ça quand on
atteint un certain âge aussi moi je
commence à comprendre ce que ça veut
dire les amitiés qui durent depuis
longtemps les connaissances aussi qui
dure depuis longtemps mais qui qui
reviennent ponctuellement dans ta vie
qui sont témoins de ce que tu as vécu
puis de toi-même donc c'est vraiment
touchant je pense comme comme série
Céline Bonnie après la sortie d'honneur
d'Albanie genre de vous retrouver en
usine C en 2023 avec le cycle le
shakespearien merci beaucoup Céline
merci